Leandro est un gars incroyable
dans un bidonville de Rio.
Il a lancé un projet de recyclage dans le bidonville.
A la fin de l'année dernière, le 16 décembre,
il a reçu un arrêté d'expulsion
du gouvernement de l’État de Rio de Janeiro,
lui donnant deux semaines pour vider les lieux
qu'il occupait depuis deux ans.
Le plan était de céder le terrain à un promoteur,
qui avait prévu de le transformer en chantier de construction.
Leandro a commencé une campagne avec l'un de nos outils,
la Cocotte Minute,
le même outil utilisé par Bia et Jovita,
et le gouvernement d’État a changé d'avis
avant la Noël.
Ces histoires me réjouissent,
pas seulement parce qu'elles se terminent bien.
Elles me réjouissent parce qu'elles sont
de bons commencements.
La communauté d'enseignants et de parents
de l'école de Bia cherche d'autres manières
d'améliorer l'endroit encore davantage.
Leandro a des grands projets
de transposer son modèle dans d'autres communautés pauvres de Rio,
et Jovita est bénévole dans l'unité de police
qu'elle a aidé à créer.
Bia, Jovita et Leandro
sont les exemples vivants de quelque chose
que les citoyens et les municipalités dans le monde
doivent savoir :
Nous sommes prêts.
Comme citoyens, nous sommes prêts
à décider de notre destin commun,
parce que nous savons que la manière dont nous distribuons le pouvoir
en dit long sur la valeur que nous accordons aux autres,
et parce que nous savons
que permettre la participation à la politique locale
est un signe que nos relations avec les autres
nous tiennent à cœur,
et que nous sommes prêts à agir
dans les villes du monde entier dès à présent.
Avec le réseau ''Our Cities'',
l'équipe Meu Rio espère
partager ce que nous avons appris
avec d'autres personnes qui veulent lancer
des projets semblables dans leurs villes.
Nous avons déjà commencé à le faire à São Paulo
avec d'incroyables résultats,
et nous voulons exporter cette idée à travers le monde
à travers un réseau d'organisations
centrées sur les citoyens et dirigées par eux,
et qui pourrait nous inspirer,
nous lancer le défi, et nous rappeler de revendiquer
une vraie participation dans la vie de nos cités.
C'est à nous de décider
si nous voulons des écoles
ou des parkings,
des projets de recyclage gérés par le quartier,
ou des chantiers de construction,
la solitude ou la solidarité, des autos ou des bus
et c'est notre responsabilité de le faire maintenant
pour nous-même, pour nos familles,
pour tous ceux qui font que notre vie vaut la peine d'être vécue
et pour l'incroyable créativité, les beautés et les merveilles
qui font de nos villes,
en dépit de tous leurs problèmes,
l'invention la plus importante de notre ère.
Obrigado. Merci.
(Applaudissements)